bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fatti j
e non ci siano su david pizarro non mi
ricordavo il titolo lug i ragazzi mi
avete 20 moltissimi dal mio rientro
delle vacanze che questo sarebbe stato
uno degli indie horror più spaventosi
che avrei mai provato è la cosa mi ha
incuriosito un catino quindi nel 1994
una presenza demoniaca entrata in
un'altra dimensione ha dovuto affrontare
faccia a faccia le sue paure porca
miseria se una volta finisco mai di
leggere non un'idea di dove di che
diavolo sia successo ma non fa niente
andiamo avanti così press è ok a sono
andato a dormire a c'è
meglio di così giorno se io sono entrati
in una casa cosa diavolo est opposto
maledizione cioè cos'è 22 quale 42 una
lezione di matematica questa lezione non
avrà mai fine
è una lezione che non finisce mai cazzo
è l'incubo di ogni studente io non ho
italy dove sto andando cos'è cosa fa
che bei banchi m'ispirano troppo e
quindi che cazzo dovrebbe rappresentarli
sta cosa ragazzi qua c'è del sangue la
cosa bruttissima e non posso vedere cosa
ci attraverso la cosa mi inquieta
parecchio
vabbè comunque io lì non ci voglio
entrare a prescindere quindi non me ne
frega nulla me ne vado
grazie cos'è cos'è cos'è stato trovato
perfetto ho trovato un piede di porco
ragazzi a qualcosa mi dovrà servire al
massimo se spunta qualcuno posso
darglielo in testa questo è sicuro
adesso vedo di andare se riesco il piano
di sopra che ancora non ho visto ma che
cazzo è successo qui ragazzino questa
era era chiusa prima era chiusa era
fottutamente chiusa siamo ufficialmente
nella merda perché qualcosa è uscito da
quella stanza lì e la cosa non mi piace
devo riuscire ad aprire qualcosa posta
roba non so che cosa pensare
chi c'è nel bagno delle donne esci fuori
tu un uomo brutto e cattivo che non si
entra nel bagno delle ragazze a meno che
non sia un mostro in gonnella
credo che debba sì perfetto allora
faccio molto piano è ok ho fatto
perfetto sono un gentleman sono sicuro
di essere nel bagno delle ragazze perché
qualcuno ha qui aveva il suo periodo mi
sa perché sono tante le chiazze di
sangue comunque dobbiamo andare cazzo è
successo è un quiz fermi papa ok ok non
c'è nessuno perfetto c'era una tizia non
molto truccata in questo bagno non so
che cosa ci faceva qui ma la cosa non mi
piace ciò ancora un cesso ad aprire bene
bene allora io io me ne vado dalle palle
ho trovato una chiave nel una chiave nel
cesso perfetto ragazzi voi non vi capita
mai di trovare chiavi nel cesso che cosa
cazzo è successo al muro ok io possa
smettere di giocare qui cosa cazzo
ragazzi ragazzi perché la sedia la sta
tirando su qualcuno sentite ma adesso
che mi fa male il culo dove lo metto che
non c'è più una sedia allora vabbè non
fa niente
una mattata sembra quasi poesia hakuna
matata tutta frenesia d'enza pensieri la
tua vita sarà non si accende più la
torcia ok ragazzi credo che io devo
andare qui dentro io non vi giuro che
non lo farei ma non mi è rimasto
diventato quindi dove andare devo andare
per forza avanti quindi i ragazzi con
calma con calma ok non vedo un cazzo di
niente dove sto io sbatto la la faccia
contro un palo perché non vedo un
perfetto
ok siamo siamo vivi incredibilmente non
ci posso credere
credo che
acito affanculo ragazzi io non ho visto
non ho idea di che cosa sia successo ma
fatemi ok ok grazie a dio effettivamente
l'ultimo posto dove dovrei andare in un
posto di merda sono i sotterranei di
quel posto di merda ma dove siamo noi
ovviamente nei sotterranei e siamo pure
caduti nelle scale dei sotterranei del
posto di me comunque andiamo andiamo
avanti ii qua se riusciamo perfetto io
non so dove sto andando effettivamente
ma sto andando avanti perché non ho
altre vie non so dove andare se noi che
c'è una gabbia che chi ci chiudono
dentro
anzi volentieri mitch chiudo io
piuttosto che stanno a cuore con quel
tizio con tiziano kalinic
ho visto una [ __ ] ombra sul pavimento
e non contratti tali perché l'avete
vista anche voi sono qui a tirare lab e
a caso perché non ho capito cosa devo
fare comunque credo che di aver fatto la
cosa giusta anche se non so cosa anche
ragazzi non ho capito che cosa serve
quella fare ma qualcosa di sicuro ho
fatto quindi torniamo indietro tanto mi
pare che sia un sogno alla fine c'è
scritto dreaming ogni tre secondi quindi
non lo so sarà tipo un sogno
sì ma chi dice di sognare una torcia
accesa pensa che io abbia cattive
intenzioni
svetta di testa è no no non ho presa
scusami vabbè il prossimo cross vai vai
di testa direttamente ok senti york
premier tempo che preme r o luce grazie
a dio è una e una lampadina di natale
cos'è sta roba da tanto non era entrato
di la prima che cosa ci faccio qui ho
sbagliato ho sbagliato ingresso era
l'altro l'ingresso vabbè comunque
andiamo avanti e spero di trovare cos'è
sta roba
mi sto pagando addosso e non vorrei
dirvelo ma sono costretto a farlo perché
se non mio mi vivi moglie d'infarto qui
chi è chi ha coperto passaggio o bevuto
troppo io non lo so ragazzi non mi
interessa andiamo su per favore perché
sta diventando arrivi a tanto
se non sbaglio c'era il ragazzo che
aveva acceso la luce uscita uscita
ragazzi c'è scritto uscita io vado dove
c'è scritto uscita perché sono un genio
e sono sicuro bravi ragazzi ma riuscire
o forse no ok io forse no benissimo e io
io grazie mille
via di qui ragazzi ma così come stimato
dall altra parte che dite
gli oli ecco il corridoio non ci metto
più piede voi pensate malissimo
andiamo di qualche mi sembra più sicuro
di quello di prima perché almeno qua non
mi sputeranno fantasmi nei corridoi vero
novero non solo perché siete tanto buoni
cos'è sta roba alla classe di musica che
a me mettiamo maicon skrillex
[Musica]
spero che la lezione mi sia piaciuta il
78 di musica più azzeccato nella storia
che cos'è prese dove ho trovato una
chiave a caso così credo che sia quella
dell'app di corridoio principale credo e
non ne sono sicuro credo che debba
arrivare a quella porta rossa ma non ne
sono sicuro va bè l'importante è che
stavolta chiave mi apro qualcosa perché
un altro po mi perdo e non so più dove
andare allora credo sia questa
ok fatti ci avrei scommesso permesso
allora è perfetto questa sostanza di
disegno io so disegnare da dio
io mi offro volontario è ok devo devo
che cosa cosa c'è qui riassetti posso
prendere il registro di classe scriverci
fa vj fa le puzzette no non ragazzi che
possono fare qui ho preso un registro
bene che cosa mi serve al tratto ci sono
chiazze di sangue ovunque voi dovete
spiegarmi che cosa ma che con cosa
dipingete con la tempera con il sangue
fatemi capire ho preso registro mano
della visitazione salta perché gioca
salta pensato più a rallenti del mondo
perfetto se ce l'abbiamo fatta un salto
epico e non ha saltato però lei non ha
saldato giardini score di 8 studenti
capita a volte che ci entrerei nel
dubbio perfetto bravo così morendo ok
evitiamo la sono solo all'inizio
ok mi sono risvegliato nel letto dove
ero all'inizio mi ero addormentato il
suo posto non so perché ho finito si no
cos'è thank you for plein
ma no mi aspettavo una cosa finale del
tipo uno spavento o un colpo di scena va
bè ragazzi la morale di questa cosa è se
sei stanco di andare a scuola prova vi
metto di notte fa i sogni del genere e
mi raccomando non prendete al registro
dell'insegnante quando non lo sa anche
ragazzi credo che gli infarti possano
bastare spero di andare a dormire
tranquillo stasera ma ne dubito comunque
ragazzi vi ringrazio di cuore per avermi
consigliato questo gioco come al solito
siete fantastici e se video è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato un commento vi
piace anche la pagina di facebook come
non i video tratte nella descrizione
seno essere per iscritti sgretolino ci
vediamo il prossimo video basta ragazzi